Florida Governor Ron DeSantis trying to
shake up the 2024 race after officially
launching his bid for the White House
and calling it The Great American
comeback but it was a rocky start to
Santa's campaign kickoff on Twitter was
marred by a slew of technical
difficulties DeSantis later joined Fox
News host Trey Gowdy for his first
interview as a presidential candidate
we know the country's on the wrong track
we see it with our eyes we feel it in
our bones we see the Border being
overrun we see crime infesting to cities
we see the federal government making it
more difficult for families to make ends
meet what I will do is help restore
normalcy to our communities Integrity to
our institutions and Sanity to our
society truth needs to be the foundation
of everything we do and Common Sense can
no longer be an uncommon virtue range
DeSantis is now going toe-to-toe with
former president Trump but a new Fox
News poll shows that Trump still has a
commanding lead for the GOP nomination
Florida Governor is also facing a
hostile media who are not too thrilled
about his candidacy
it's a mess you know get just get out of
the race you're not going to win
nothing's going to happen for him
nothing I think he has a really great
chance at becoming the president of
Florida
but outside of Florida as you say these
are really really unpopular I just think
it was an unbelievable miscalculation
from the very beginning conceptually it
was wrong and execution it was a
disaster it was bad I mean it was bad on
on so many fronts
you know Greg in the hindsight does does
Santa's get any credit for trying to do
something unusual yeah I mean you know
is it a situation where or should he
have just have done a rally or maybe a
video like I think I think you got to do
new things politicians all sound the
same and I think glitches actually
Amplified the story I wouldn't even have
known about it if I hadn't heard that it
was screwed up but you know I've been on
this Earth a long time you know at least
three decades or four
and every Republican candidate is always
worse than the one before it right so
Reagan Ronald Reagan was Hitler then
came Bush worse than Hitler then another
Bush worse than worse than Hitler then
McCain lizard Hitler Romney misogynist
animal torturer Hitler then Trump comes
on he's really worse than Hitler and now
according to CNN DeSantis is worse than
Trump making him worse than worse than
Hitler so as long as we have this brand
of demonization by the Democrats and the
media you're never going to have a
candidate that is Trump minus the drama
because they're always going to create
the drama on top of everybody
Vanity Fair already calls DeSantis a
white supremacist they tell people
Hillary says don't go to Florida it's a
threat to your personal safety this is
something about Governor DeSantis who
really looks like a nerdy version of
Bradley Cooper let's be honest he is not
a threat but these but these networks
are now going to be in a quandary
especially CNN they're already in
trouble if you don't say DeSantis is as
dangerous as Trump that's an endorsement
for DeSantis so if you say he's worse
than Trump then you look like an ass
because you've been pumping out this
hysteria that Trump was an existential
threat and now you find a new
existential threat that's worse
people already see through this it can't
last forever I don't know but you know
the truth is uh Harold that the Trump
hatred has lasted forever but at the
same time uh that Trump still has the
highest numbers the biggest number and
the people who are with Trump are dug in
with Trump so is this really about uh
Biden as opposed uh running against
DeSantis as opposed to uh Biden running
against Trump does it come down to
whether or not they hate Trump more or
is it that uh that DeSantis has a chance
to catch up and be as big as Trump
against Biden did that make any sense
I'll always understand what you're
saying judge and I my take on him is
this
um the Santa's uh six to eight weeks ago
was a stronger candidate than the
santhis is today largely because of the
last eight weeks Donald Trump's numbers
have grown and his numbers have shrunk
so I think Trump remains a formidable uh
in the front run on the Republican side
I agree with with with Greg in one
regard I think a lot of people would
never have known he announced the vast
majority of Americans that have not been
told that he had a glitch with the thing
with Twitter that being said I'm old
school I think when you run for public
office particularly for president and
you're announcing it visuals are
important particularly for a candidate
who many people say had might have some
difficulty interacting with people uh
that he may have some views that may not
be consistent with sort of a national
mainstream set of views I would think
you would have wanted to have a visual
and let people like you let people see
that there's something appealing about
she's a good looking guy to be to be
compared to Bradley Cooper is a good
thing so to see to be on television and
lay out your views and the layouts your
your path too it would give them an
opportunity even more so to say Mr Trump
I want to debate you I would have ended
my launch speech if I were him saying Mr
President I understand you don't want to
debate me perhaps you don't want to
debate me because my ideas are superior
but whatever the case I hope you will
debate me and three I think Karl Rove
nailed it today in the in the uh in the
Wall Street Journal I don't I don't
always agree with Carl but I read him
every week because I think he's smart I
think we're seeing it we're seeing
seeing a big battle set up in the
Republican primary between the Tim Scott
brand of politics which is sunny kind of
positive can link it to Reagan and those
that are that are not I'm not saying
that Donald Trump is is not sunny but
his his approach to campaigning is very
different and sometimes can be punishing
so we'll see where will you announce on
the five
yes
I am the glitch all right you know what
Dana on Fox news last night uh DeSantis
talked about things like policy things
like the border and crime and inflation
how did those points uh compare to the
the value pointing of the woke ideology
that's it's a great great question so I
think that one of the things he has
demonstrated now that people get to see
him a little bit more like on in that
interview that Trey did last night is a
policy fluidity with complete competence
and an example for everything that he's
talking about and he doesn't hesitate
and he knows his stuff okay so if that's
what you're looking for that is pretty
interesting for people the the launch
what maybe it wasn't great but I'm
thinking about Elon Musk he's willing to
have a two billion dollar rocket blow up
as an experiment just to see what could
we learn here so I think that one of the
things that they did last night was find
out oh okay Twitter spaces needs a
little work okay now
maybe I'm going to be splitting hairs
here but let me do it for the for for
their perspective last night was an
announcement that Ron DeSantis is
running for president
the camp his campaign office is billing
next Tuesday in Iowa as their campaign
kickoff event and that's where I think
Harold you're going to see a little bit
more of the tradition that you are
mentioning I think that some launches
are memorable most are not let me tell
you one that's memorable Kamala Harris
amazing launch remember all the people
that were there and even president Trump
at the time said wow she's got a she's
got a good chance she was the first one
to drop out so the launch doesn't really
matter it's what happens after that one
of the things that is a challenge and an
opportunity for Rhonda Santos is there
is a lot of misconception out there
amongst people I heard somebody today
say well isn't he like advancing racist
policies and isn't he against gay people
and isn't he banning all the books and I
started to try to explain on their
behalf and I thought wait well that's
not my job that's his job and he's got a
big one in front of him on that front
yeah he does have a big job but you know
Lawrence you know Biden's uh numbers are
in the 30s I mean in Kamala I mean talk
about her falling out I mean she's even
below that I mean how is it that that
Biden is so strong against some of the
Republicans what is that about
um I don't think he's strong honestly
I know
um I I think that he had his shot 52 of
Americans felt like under Donald Trump
that
um their lives were better and they
chose Joe Biden strictly because they
wanted to bring down the temperature and
that he was supposed to be the Elder
statement and all that nonsense well
that's over that's over uh we've seen
how he's governed he didn't unify the
country life is not better under him and
it's easy to vote based on emotion when
life is good for you now you got people
losing their businesses you got egg
prices going up which is why I think as
I travel the country
the Republican base and I think people
discount them so much but they are not
moving they're not moving and they want
a fire brand as well
he didn't do that last night desensis it
was boring it was Dale Estelle and he
was reading off a paper I can tell
because his Cadence changed when he was
with Trey he had a little bit of motion
there and if you drink hair well it may
be changed it got his attention if you
want to take on the leader of the
Republican party and someone listen I
I'll tell you this there's a reason why
um people people aren't afraid of Donald
Trump in Washington they're afraid of
his voters in the Republican party they
know the way he's able to gravitate them
because he's the first one that bypass
the typical Washington stuff and listen
to them
the senses as polished as he is he's
still a typical politician and he showed
that last night and if he wants to take
on Donald Trump he's going to have to
change
um your strategy hiring the same
consultant and I know all of them is not
going to help you bud there's a lot of
people that were Polished in 2016. Ted
Cruz was known as a fire brand and
conservatism
put the policy debate out there knows
the Constitution by heart you got Rand
Paul that was on the stage Jeb Bush that
inherit a political family that knows
all the things to do and it still did
not work so if you're gonna run against
him and I know defense is one of his
talking points is now I'm the only one
that can win I heard that in 2016 as
well yeah so you got to make a different
debate all right hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else